I want you to remember back to when
we're doing what's down we'll go
approximately as I said can you
approximate from the root three and the
way we have to do that was to form a
polynomial that would do the job right
well polynomial do you form to find the
square roots of 3 plus 4 right what's
sad is the square yeah good I want some
knob on some coffee Trump is in such a
way I square it I end up with this yeah
does that make sense and once I saw that
I'll be fine
so you want to remember back okay every
complex number is in the form X plus iy
it's going to apply to his imaginary pot
and so when you square that a fixed
original fine you're not going to get x
squared plus y squared you're gonna get
x squared minus y squared cos sin Phi
squared y squared so there's my real
component and then I'm gonna have my
magic gxy
and because as your business that
becomes crucial later on because
otherwise what would happen makes my
went real well
it makes my went really hit you get you
get more roots and also just be more
fundamental there's no guarantees it
would be like what would they be it
wouldn't necessarily have a real
we compared it which was what we wanted
to make by definition all right so you
skip a little bit down but you're gonna
have to pull your two equations right
what are you going to get 4x squared
minus y squared is that's three and then
you've got your 2 X 1 I so I go to
explain which is equal to four okay so
out of this you can change rearrange to
make it whichever one you want these are
symmetric equations so if you make Y the
subject or exit subject you're still
gonna get the same answer I think I went
about it that way which gives me this
yeah okay now what do you do with that
what happens there I'm gonna multiplex
your I swear that gave me a quarter
okay once you get through to your port
you go ahead and solve what's the
factorization you go plus
there you go and you can see here this
is why I was so important that we have
identified that was real because I'm not
going to get any solutions out of that
right so I would say since X is real but
X must be plus or minus 2 totally ok I
think that's important that we wore
reasons
sorry or solutions for a reason since I
but x equals 2 and x equals negative 2
there are y values that come along with
that which will give us our actual
points when x equals 2
what's y equal to 1 or x equals negative
2 ok ok how's your plot loop is you're a
hugger and diagram with did you remember
to plot your original complex that
materials for eyes okay now I'm really
hurt you're doing a decent diagram here
because you will love you'll be able to
follow along ends and see all the
remember the beauties I again the
biggest number would have is 3 plus 4i
so I'm going to go 1 2 3
one two three four sir ah Keung there is
three plus four right okay whereabouts
you spirits relation to that so I can do
the festival to one family he's linked
to plus five that's my first 90 percent
I'm gonna call this a one and of course
said to who is that it's just on the
opposite side of the origin right so if
I put my own
okay now I'm going to use this as our
opportunity to remember when you treat
complex numbers not just as points but
as vectors you get to take advantage of
all this beautiful geometry that's just
in you're into complex numbers okay
in particular if you recall compare your
to roots to the original if you've drawn
you as well in your scale is even
half-decent
you should be able to easily see that
the argument of Z 1 is clearly half the
argument of this where do you see it
like that has to be thinner even if your
diagram is not that not back then you
should be able to see cuz you know
coming up to three or four not that
complicated right and you can even see
on my life I meant no emissions to those
complete estimate and it's already
almost peasantry huh those that use
there it's an argue it on my scheme to
the original embers to theta
what's an argument to the other spirit
you can think this in a variety of ways
if I went to the principal argument I
would go up there this way right I would
say I came for a second this is going to
be negative PI to get to there but then
I'm gonna be able to come back right I
could do that for reasons that we come
here a sec just to remind you I'm
actually gonna go to the other way and
not have the principal Bible so what is
the size what's the magnitude of that up
I go to apply and then I go an extra
Thea do you agree with that so that's PI
plus theta okay now he's visiting what
is it what that the
arguments there for the first route half
here because if we Square this and she
get out to here and when you multiply a
complex number
what do you do to the arguments you add
arguments right remember this you add on
so you get beat up you add it again and
up you watch TV that makes sense what
are these other one what happens to here
is M cheese all the way up here she got
plant must feed on where you multiply by
this again add the same argument what
happened to you doubled its to plant
those to Thea but of course to pine is
just the full revolution so you need to
worry about it and you've got the two
theta beautiful all right in fact
that's to climb closer to you know which
is actually tough to do right my last
little bit just to do a bit of
Pythagoras quickly right
that was the arguments what's the
modulus to the square roots modulus is
the same it's refined
because this is 1/2 so it's the square
root of once papers to square this
advancement refine and then when you
have a look at the original complex
number this is 3/4 this is the
quintessential might be great triad
that's fine because of course when you
multiply complex elements you add eyes
and use multiplying mods yes is it
coming back to you